[Music]
obviously this is an incredible dream
come true to enter into the world of
late night and uh one of my late night
heroes was actually kind enough to sit
down with me on his set in new york and
give me some pointers so would you like
to watch that video while i also watch
it
let's watch that video
see how i have this show rigged look at
us right now look at us look at us on
camera right now you would think we were
equivalent adults and yet stand up
hello
i'm regis but what sit down again this
is the magic of being a talk show host
see here's your first lesson right now
yeah
rig the whole show to your advantage so
on my show i could make me not look like
an ogre
let's not get crazy it's not going to be
cgi
i'm very excited for you thank you pete
holmes did warm up for us that's true
for a very short amount of time because
uh you were very good i never would have
sat here or touched this desk i'm
freaking out a little bit
you know why why it's covered in ricin
there is no way that that's true here's
your first piece of advice about a talk
show yeah please a lot of people are
gonna be bullshitting you
you're gonna need to toughen up opie
you're gonna need to bring it you're
gonna need to bring the cynicism i'm
gonna do my best papa all right
i prepped a lot for this interview all
right did you prep at all to talk with
me
yeah a lot of purell a lot of purell
what do you keep in your desk do you
have anything in here uh i don't have it
it's not really a desk there's uh
i mean pens i have a pen
and um
there's a clock it's just a regular pen
sure yeah a man's pen
yeah no it's just your standard uh round
stick they call it the round stick 29
cents a piece
and uh i use them as an implement of uh
writing
was that a good question
that's so good
i'd love to come on the show because
when you promote a book it you get that
yeah yeah you mean when we're on the air
when you're on the air yeah no
no we're not going to do that
not on not only
hold on let me think would say no
let me
you know what maybe i could just hold on
let me say no
that was nothing you had nothing it's no
or
no
[Laughter]
so you host the daily show you just
finished up directing is that right a
movie and uh you're a great dad
i just want to know how you balance an
actual life with this mania
pete you you really don't
that's that's the secret here is uh
surrender you're on your way to being a
shell of a man
all i can say is
welcome to the team
purell
[Applause]
[Music]